if it isn't allowed in the streets it
shouldn't be allowed on the net we have
a group a hardcore small group of
individuals amongst that who will lie
who will Menace who will believe we know
they're becoming bolder and a lot of
what they're posting is becoming much
more sinister nobody who suffered such a
tragedy in their lives should have to
cope with that on their own the audience
that some of them need is actually from
the dock in court so they can be held to
account for the things which they have
done
[Music]
this woman uses Twitter to attack the
parents of Madeleine McCann on the
Internet
she's anonymous not anymore let me talk
to you about your Twitter no tax on them
account no why are you attacking them so
regularly look I'm just going out with a
friend okay but why are you using your
Twitter account to attack
you know you can report it to the police
just open the arms they're considering a
whole file of Twitter accounts and what
supporter says a campaign of abuse
the Crown Prosecution Service is
considering it are you worried about
that
on Twitter she uses the name sweepy face
and a profile picture of a pet she
tweets many times a day and mostly about
the McCanns in one message she spread
rumors about the couple's marriage in
another she hoped Madeline's parents
would suffer forever but sweepy face is
not the worst
[Music]
almost from the day Madeline vanished
seven years ago her family have been
targeted with vile messages on the
Internet
what's cannot describe the anguish and
despair many cannot forgive her parents
Kate and Gerry McCann for leaving
Madeline and her twin siblings alone in
bed while they had dinner nearby
some have urged violence against the
parents others have gone even further
offering support for anyone who is
prepared to seriously harm the McCanns
everyone's entitled to an opinion
everyone's entitled to stay at that but
when it becomes grossly offensive when
it becomes menacing when it's causing
anxiety and under stress when it's done
for that purpose then there must be a
criminal justice intervention and this
has gone on for too long and let me say
this if this was a high-profile you know
celebrity or other individual that was
something would be done about it by now
a dossier containing evidence of
hundreds of malicious and threatening
Internet postings has been sent to the
Commissioner of Scotland Yard
it calls for a police clamped down on
the online abuse it's been compiled by a
group of web users appalled at the
attacks on the McCanns the Metropolitan
Police told the group this material has
now been forwarded to us here at the
operational investigation team dealing
with the disappearance of Madeleine
McCann operation Grange in consultation
with the Crown Prosecution Service and
the McCann family the material will now
be assessed and decisions made as to
what further action if any should be
undertaken the woman who organized the
dossier said she contacted police
because the abuse was getting worse and
Internet service providers refused to
help stop it
because she's so worried about her own
safety we have hidden her identity and
dubbed her voice
she also fears for the McCanns we're
talking about materials which a libelous
completely untrue lots of photoshopped
images of the McCanns very cruel in
nature offensive and we were getting
nowhere by reporting it to the sites and
as it steadily got worse we were finding
people going online who were claiming to
live near the McCanns we're very worried
that it's only going to take somebody to
act out some of these discussions some
of the threats have been made and we
couldn't live with ourselves that that
happened and we done nothing a
[Music]
photograph of Madeline's twin siblings
was posted online after the McCann
family were caught on a TV camera at the
Commonwealth Games in Glasgow this
summer we have obscured the children's
faces it prompted a discussion about the
twins one commentator described the
color of their hair
another question their safety the twins
are now 9 years old and as their parents
have said they're beginning to use the
Internet another social media outlet for
the macaron attackers is Facebook with
sites that appear to have been set up as
platforms for criticism and accusations
this site boasts more than 24 thousand
members another site has 34,000 a recent
book about the Madeleine McCann case
explored the online abuse it provoked a
campaign to flood the Amazon website
with negative reviews in a bid to limit
the book sales our book documents the
fact that over the last seven years a
core group of people has perpetuated the
idea that the McCanns had something to
do with their daughter's disappearance
these people give legitimacy to the
online nuts
trolls and haters people who just want
to sit behind their computers and spread
venom and they do and the new dossier
that presented to the Met is actually
frightening in that it suggests action
against family members it suggests
stalking of family members it's pretty
extreme in the past Kate and Gerry
McCann have refused to comment on the
online abuse they suffer because they
didn't want to fuel it they've long been
aware of their critics in the UK
Portugal and Beyond but there's evidence
that some of their attackers are much
nearer to their home in Raleigh in
Leicester Shearer the dossier includes
Twitter postings that suggest some
people have been physically close to the
couple tweets alleged sightings of them
at their local gym the post office and a
clothes shop one tweeter wrote that he
was trying to find Kate McCann if the
Metropolitan Police haven't already
begun an investigation into this on the
back of of letters or complaints that
they've received I think they know I
need to pause they need to take a long
look at it they need to reflect on the
legislation that exists to deal with us
under the Communications Act malicious
communications act and Prevention of
harassment act and they need to look at
the hardcore few who are being menacing
who are being maligned who are creating
an anxiety deliberately I don't want to
give this small maligne a malicious
group a larger audience than they have
I think the audience that some of them
need is actually from the doc in court
so they can be held to account for the
things which they have done and that
will send a strong message to many
others the internet is not anonymous the
police have the ability to identify the
individuals that are doing this
some antagonists specialize in
manipulating photographs to attack the
McCanns a common theme is the accusation
that Madeline's parents have cashed in
on their daughter's disappearance using
for themselves the thousands of pounds
raised by the model
fund this example shows how an innocent
original image was doctored to ridicule
the McCanns others make their own spoof
videos and post them online a DVD of the
worst has been handed to police this is
the dossier that's been sent to the
commissioner at Scotland Yard all 67
pages of it the letter that went with it
urged detectives to take urgent action
they say it demonstrates an organized
campaign of abuse intimidation and
threats against the McCann family their
group argues that if these so-called
internet trolls formed a mob and shouted
their abuse at their targets in the
street then the police would intervene
there are those on Twitter who believe
they are beyond the law some troll
victims like MP Stella Creasy have got
justice a man who used Twitter to
threaten her with rape was jailed this
week another man who targeted stabbed
leads school teacher and McGuire was
also imprisoned he used Facebook to say
he was glad she had died and when
Liverpool footballer Mario Balotelli
suffered racial abuse on Twitter
Merseyside police launched an
investigation straight away I think a
lot of them don't realize what they're
getting into a lot of them are just
random transient people who just post a
comment and join in with discussions but
there's a hardcore group who've been
there from the beginning so if the
technology is there to deal with them
why can't they not apply that to one of
the worst cases of cyberbullying we've
come across
okay thank you after our initial
exchange with sweepy face she invited us
in off-camera she explained more about
the anonymous tweets she sends from the
heart of this pretty village she had
questions for the McCanns she believed
Twitter was a vehicle for expressing
those thoughts she will probably never
tweet again she hoped she hadn't broken
the law
sweepy face and the many others whose
comments have been recorded may find
that Scotland Yard will take a different
view
Martin brunt Sky News
you